let's see what you rascals have been up
to
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old and i'll measure your pp's in the
last episode of lawyer
after 700 clips around 25 different
videos and three weeks of work
okay oh it feels so good to be a
gangster oh yeah
pow pow
dead dead pow pow
we'll never
i would be panic
embarrassed to be him right now
hunter by night
but performer by day
my dream is too wide
i came a long way
[Music]
[Music]
backwards thinking which i know you do
all the time which one came first
chicken egg you tell me it's a
cautionary this is so [ __ ] i think it's
serious to all these people i have a
higher level of intellect
how is that a facebook that's
[Music]
[Music]
that's my
[Music]
you seem distracted disinterested
distant disappointed just like
downloading
at this point it's important that we
call these things out
only wrong answers laughs
to play devil's advocate just for a
minute if i accuse everyone then you
don't need it question answer problem
fix it thanks for asking that's the
secret
[Music]
uh this made me realize two things first
of all amazing uh hide spikes that was
so good do i have one sweat i have one
sweater guys check out tsuki.market it's
a brand me and marcia do together
it's the only sweater you need check out
the mischief's collection and you can
get uh it's sold out well you can get
the mischief shirt
chip pants
mischief tea coming up hunt for the
summer ethically made in canada and
super soft casually watching a video
this video is
by tsuki dot market
i buy youtube premium because i don't
want any ads before we start today's
video let's talk about my sponsor i wish
youtube would do what spotify does well
i guess you can do that you can make a
chapter maybe i should do that from now
on so you guys know how long the ad is i
feel like it's fair listen i gotta say
thank you to you guys for being patient
with the ad reads a little inside
information here of how dumb i am they
pay you based on like uh 60 seconds or
90 second ad right but they give you all
this information so it's impossible to
deliver all this information that they
want they're like tell them all these
things in three seconds but like i can't
do that well we're only paying you three
seconds so that's why they always go out
longer i mean i could just cut it but
then i feel like while you're paying me
i should at least deliver but then again
maybe i'm just a pushover i'm sorry i
basically i'm sorry i'm sorry for being
bad at ad reads rate my setup 10 out of
10. let's go
is he making pump is that popcorn
okay
i forgot about him
no he was like a father to me this one
happens when i don't upload daily
anymore like this big trends just come
and go and i haven't even had a chance
to react to it yet it's like oh cool
yeah our place that was cool right this
is the worst thing i've ever seen in my
life
is that her was that her in the matrix
mess with me
because i will fight you
bring it on
but can you do this
yeah
miss peach bro will smith's whack as
hell dude [ __ ] the call that sends
rewind
yeah all right
it's funny because it's true i'm sorry
my parents entered just at the moment
where he was sucking his finger and now
i'm grounded and my dad told me about
the birds and the bees now me crying
because i finally met pubes
oh this is a marcia's pop-up shot and i
was helping out there i am
[Laughter]
kind of weird to just record someone if
you ever see him again just say hi well
she did just say hi and it was totally
fine i feel like in that shop it was
kind of expected that people were gonna
do that so i really don't mind it's more
like weird if i'm on the street or
something yeah
let's go
that's a menstrual heating pad i put the
menstrual heating pad on my eyes i'm
such a [ __ ] idiot
you do feel good though not gonna lie
dead youtube channel youtube shorts well
i guess we're making youtube shorts now
i just want to be relevant not make any
money
just please be relevant hey okay
we we lived for a small moment that's
cool before germany invaded us god damn
it
that's cool
yeah
yeah
right
yes
holy [ __ ] i'm still here what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ryan brought some cool stuff yeah thanks
to everyone for coming uh it was a
really big success what is his photo oh
she got a sticker oh you you're the
norwegian
oh the most awkward interrupt yeah i
remember you you're the norwegian dude
yeah
you spoke in a reading too man i guess
my scandinavian brain wasn't turned on i
was like what what are you doing what
are you doing
and then he's like should i buy this
cooking dharma and i'm like yeah sure
and then i guess he did
it was fun it was not that awkward come
on babe
hey that looks amazing cool love it
amazing progress love edgar looking evil
as hell i work at dharma and after lots
of trying my phone case finally made it
to the last video
we've infiltrated the dow man system
so random
i love that
huge peepee
oh that's [ __ ] funny can't alive
can't hear can't remember
yes handel's bunker i try to do this my
bank doesn't allow it so lame very
ecstatic looking good my dude
there was a brief period where i thought
i was becoming an adult and then i said
no i ain't doing it are you watching all
pewdiepie videos i missed a funny
pewdiepie he's retired he can do
whatever he wants yes i miss his
hilarious uploads stop criticizing him
he was great fun back then
half of this subreddit
just watch this subreddit in like five
years and be like i loved when he was
just retired and doing whatever he wants
maybe i should just instead quit and
then whenever i come back and upload
videos like yay
retired sounds lame ali i've actually
seen this one it's sick
can't even i can't even see what's going
on
i guess i know some of the flint hey
i don't think that was by the uploader
but it's a very good one no pain no gain
hell yeah i got to put up this poster in
my japanese gym
this just want to show my progress thank
you felix inspired me a lot god damn
hell yeah good job man my game will
about a battle royale inside an ikea is
finally releasing soon
it actually makes sense that fortnight
would be them with all the building
right that's what fortnite wanted to be
i guess fortnite is swedish and i think
about it so i saw your workout video and
i'm impressed how much you've gone
but i just wanted to show you a better
way to
get your dumbbells up to your chest yeah
yeah listen i know i know video
you swung your dumbbell i know you're
not whatever it doesn't matter it don't
matter with the weights i use using
heavier weight that's going to be
dangerous yeah you can't even do it
right up in here
because as you swing with heavier weight
you're going to engage that bicep
too fast with heavy weight and the
tendon is going to snap
and you're going to need surgery it
sounds like dramatic that that would
happen but it totally can happen like
you have to be careful i am aware and i
agree uh you have to be careful i feel
like with my weights it was fine uh one
of my classmates did a presentation
featuring felix
he does not know anything about him what
why would you do that okay
yes
there's the real gym playlist hey hey
monika hey put him on again
oh wow
wow nah yeah i don't
this is the thing like you see stuff
like this happening you just dish out a
video and you get millions of views and
it's super it and people like it i'm not
saying there's anything bad with it but
it's like i kind of i ain't
i don't want to do that
[Laughter]
right the subreddit is not what it used
to be hey remember when we took out the
whole nation of india look at us now
weak you're weak and pathetic but we're
still having fun and that's all that
really matters oh it shows when you
subscribe hell yeah it's been crazy well
i was in sweden the other week and
people come up to me and they're like i
watched you since i was 12 and they're
like 20.
like what
but you're an adult
oh i'm that old oh okay hey
looking good what the [ __ ] is this in
the background of peace workout video
well since me and marcia thought that we
were moving years ago we sold our flat
and moved into my office which is very
tiny and we cannot fit
everything so marxist kiln has to go in
our living room
it's that simple he doesn't know he's
the main reason i started working out
let's go get them gains
oh so someone figured out how to write a
word uh with electrons no you can't see
that this is what it looks like under a
scanning electron microscope or s is an
electron microscope and sem works by
shooting electrons at a sample instead
of light and seeing how those electrons
bounce off but what's really cool is
that if you leave the beam of electrons
in one spot too long it heats up the
sample in that area so one of my
subscribers took a jolly rancher and
focused the beam in different areas on
it to write a word smaller than a human
hair you can see the sample heat up and
bubble when the beam focuses on it for
long and then move to a new spot so
what's the grand word that he spent
hours and hours writing
he wrote pewdiepie what the hell
what that is insane i need to find the
original video i need to crown you royal
member of bro army nation happy japan
move felix as a japanese person what
makes you
roll your eyes every time you hear it uh
you need to carry cash anywhere you go
because quite a lot of places even in
central tokyo don't take hard okay i
guess i will just like die now i'm
why do people think like i don't know
all this already i've been there many
many times like
and also the same thing applies to
england you know i have to carry cash
all the time here japan is like one of
those weird countries where
so many things are very advanced but so
many things are so behind like they
still use fax machines i know there's a
ton of examples but that's just a good
one free wi-fi is hard to come by i
guess i'll die phone contracts are
inordinately expensive we didn't even
have a sim card until a few years ago
yeah all the paperwork is pretty insane
and i'm well aware of that trust me this
is weird like happy move to japan like
what are you trying to say like i don't
know this [ __ ] already no country is
perfect and i think people get the
misconception that just because we're
moving there i'm like romanticizing it
or something like every country has
problems yeah i am
shocked i'm sean the buzzfeed made a
what this happened almost three years
ago buzzfeed was finally like yeah we'll
let him off the hook he's fine it's been
three years since the controversy i
think it's okay
yeah i'm uh i'm being hopeful we've been
let down so much with the move that i'm
just like withholding any like hope i've
been really pushing all the support
lately like doing videos that i really
about stuff that i really care about
like the workout the vr video is so
funny i mean ken is always funny doing
the wish videos is always funny i don't
know this is fun uploading stuff that i
enjoy and only doing that and not just
filling the gaps on the latest trends or
whatever's popular just for the sake of
it and i know that it isn't playing the
youtube game or whatever but i'm so done
with that so i know the real ones will
stay and i appreciate you guys for being
here so that's all for now and i'll see
you guys in the next video
bros